[Music]
so you decided to play destiny 2.
maybe it's the recent disappointment of
other shooters like call of duty and
battlefield maybe it's out of curiosity
from the recent sony buyout or maybe
it's just because the latest witch queen
expansion looks awesome
welcome a lot has changed lately in
destiny and you might have some
questions about how it all works we're
here to tell you everything you need to
know to jump back into witch queen no
matter how long you've been gone we'll
have time stamps if there's a popular
question that you're dying to have
answered first but like this video sub
to the channel and seriously please
share we want to cover destiny and the
more we can bring the actual destiny
fans to our channel the more content we
can make so do it please
to get everyone on the same page destiny
2 is a constantly evolving game so if
you haven't touched it even as far back
as the shadow keep expansion when it
went free to play it might be quite
different from what you remember
and i'll be honest with you the game
actually does a pretty piss-poor job at
onboarding new players it can be
intimidating if you decide to just hop
in on your own well with all the
different vendors yelling at you to do
quests for them and the game throwing
you into a seasonal mission and wait
what there's a magical space horse or
something
the horse desires further proof of your
abilities
okay so to all of you new and relapsed
players think of this video as a q a
that will hopefully answer some of your
biggest questions as you dive into the
game quick note because the video
releases right on the eve of destiny's
latest expansion the witch queen i'll be
talking about the game from a post witch
queen release perspective the first
thing you need to know is to figure out
what destiny 2 is now
well it's not the vanilla game you may
remember that barely had an endgame we
also won't see the light dark saga that
bungie refers to as the final shape
ending for at least a couple years so
there's no point in waiting for destiny
3 yet if you've been wondering when's a
good time to play now is as good a time
as ever just don't say
i didn't warn you okay well let's get
the big hurdle out of the way what do
you actually need to buy to enjoy
destiny well destiny 2 is a free to play
game technically which means you can
load up the game and have access to a
large amount of pve content pvp modes
like the crucible and even the yearly
events you can even run around in
expansion specific locations although
there won't be much to do in them free
to play is a good way to start if you
just want to get a basic feel for the
game while avoiding getting confused
although destiny 2 is really more free
to start the real juicy meat on these
video game bones comes from the yearly
expansions this is where you get the new
gear story campaign missions activities
raids really all of the game's best
stuff if you want to see the best
destiny has to offer you'll need to pay
for the expansions this brings up
another question well which ones should
you get while conventional wisdom might
have you think that you should go in
order of release you're actually better
off picking up the most current
expansion which right now is the witch
queen there's no easy way to get caught
up on the lore and story so far in game
at least in a linear way despite those
narrative roadblocks for new players
there is an objective truth in playing
this game
destiny is at its best when you're
playing the current content with
everyone else and you're better off
focusing on what's going to give you the
best gameplay experience if later on
after wrapping up the witch queen you're
hungry to know just what the veteran
players have been a part of the last
half decade or so then you can always go
and pick up the older expansions that
are still available odds are you watch
the star wars movies out of order you
can similarly deal with destiny you'll
live
well
it is 2022 and you aren't a modern live
game if you don't have a seasonal model
so of course destiny has one seasons
typically last around three months
subject to change with four seasons
between each yearly expansion what comes
in each season can vary but it always
includes a season pass a new armor and
weapon set several new exotic weapons
new activities and about eight weeks of
story content give or take while it is
cheaper to pick up the season pass as a
bundle with witch queen i would say wait
to see if you actually like destiny
enough to keep playing for someone like
me the story content is the most
compelling part rather than waiting a
whole year for the new expansion you get
a new small story quest that continues
the narrative each week if you find
yourself invested in destiny's story
then the seasons are necessary to check
out here's a pro tip if you can spare
the time it's usually nice to log in
once a week to play through the seasonal
story beat they usually involve the same
seasonal activities but with different
dialogue variations in the level design
or maybe even changes to the world space
these differences can be minor and
exacerbated if you try to do eight weeks
of story content in one play session and
repeating the seasonal activity can feel
like a slog so enjoying them piecemeal
each week is my recommendation still of
course your mileage may vary
so you've got some gaps in your destiny
memory or you're completely new not a
problem there are plenty of ways to get
caught up but very little unfortunately
in game go to the director tab if you
are happy with just a really brief
summation you'll notice a node on the
destination map that will give you a
timeline of just the major plot points
starting with the red war which was
destiny 2 vanilla's original story
campaign not only does the game give a
brief few sentence breakdown of the big
expansions but it also describes the
evolving storyline throughout each
season the focus is to help you
understand who some of the new
characters in destiny are such as crow
or kaidel there is
technically a new light experience for
newly created characters but that
basically consists of the opening
destiny 1 sequence which is beautiful by
the way new players you guys are in for
a treat but then there's a kind of bare
bones series of quests and tours of the
tower which can help you get your
bearings for the gameplay and where the
vendors are however it doesn't fully
give you the proper backstory you might
be looking for
it's worth mentioning again that the
story at this point in time is
incredibly non-linear you'll want to
approach it maybe like a jigsaw puzzle
getting different pieces at different
times and establishing a mental timeline
if you plan on discovering the story
exclusively in game unfortunately that
means the only way you'll get caught up
on the story is by playing older content
many of which pre-shadow keep are no
longer available however let's suppose
you prefer being completely caught up
and you're the type that scours wikis or
searches youtube videos in that case you
already know that the internet can be
your friend the only issue is that there
are plenty of destiny youtubers who make
it their sole purpose to break down
destiny lore but the barrier of entry
can be high sorry bife but not everyone
has 4 hours to watch a video big fan
though good thing those for those of you
in a rush is that we got a solution for
you check out gamespot's own phil
hornshaw the man is a lore machine trust
me i play with him like every week he
eats drinks and even takes over gamespot
raid live streams with lore breakdowns
but he also has some really nice and
easy to digest story and lore catch-ups
for new and old players alike i have the
link to his articles in the description
of this video definitely check him out
new players might not know but lapsed
players are painfully aware of the level
grind between expansions particularly if
you've been away from the game for an
extended period mainly because power
level dictates what kind of activities
you can do the higher your power level
the more content you can experience
great news for everyone and the witch
queen every old and new character will
have their level at 1350 so everyone
gets an even footing to climb to the
expansion's power level cap the witch
queen has a complete refresh of new
armor to chase and there's going to be a
lot of fun new weapons to mess around
with the short answer is that you can
almost play everything solo if that's
your vibe you're also going to get
completely bombarded with people telling
you that you should play with friends or
other people and the real answer well
it's
it's honestly a mixture of the two and
it all depends on what your desired
outcome from destiny is if you are
interested in the story you definitely
want to play with like-minded friends
who also want to listen to the cutscenes
or pause their conversations to let the
radio comes and dialogue play out
because so much of destiny is told
throughout character interactions and
conversations radio chatter readable
flavor text on weapons armor pieces and
lore books all of this story is just
kind of scattered throughout the game
and this can be really hard to pay
attention to if your buddies are just
kind of chatting in your ear about their
day however that is also totally fine
because hanging out and chilling with
your friends is perfect for almost
literally everything else in destiny
i went the wrong way and then i think i
think you guys are all going the wrong
way strikes crucible gambit patrol side
quests and leveling up are absolutely
better with the group of friends just
goofing off and having a blast do you
think the one that says don't go in it
is actually the right one yeah
oh it must be
spikes
there is a
oh man
this is great it's a really fun and
smoother gameplay experience when you're
stacked with a team there are pros to
having friends that are veterans of the
game as they can potentially give you
guidance and explain questions you have
on the go as you fight the bad guys if
you want to play solo keep in mind that
certain activities have required
matchmaking strikes crucible and gambit
they'll automatically match you with
other players to cooperate or compete
against in these activities higher
difficulty content like dungeons raids
and legend level nightfalls are greater
they'll strongly suggest pre-made fire
teams of three to six players for other
parts of destiny expect to see other
players also known as blueberries pop in
and out of the area around you either in
patrol zones or the shared social spaces
like the tower say hi to one of them or
bust a dance move trust me it's a good
time
so we got a tough decision should you
start fresh or return to an old
character if you only have one character
well now is a great time to do some soul
searching and see if you actually like
the class that you chose titans yeah
they're clunky warlocks of course are
badass
and hunters are overrated i get it if
you haven't been gone for too long then
keep the old character there's no point
in going through the new light process
again and having drift or treat you like
some kind of rookie if you've already
slain a hive god or two in your time
depending on how long you've been away
from destiny one thing that you should
do immediately is set up your cross play
accounts
all your progress is saved if you decide
to play on a platform and then swap to
another at any point it is incredibly
convenient and i recommend you get it
set up if you haven't right away ah
yeah
many a content creator has built their
entire brand on telling you what guns to
use or not use it might even be their
fault that you seem to be dying to the
same exact loadout used by 90 of the
crucible population but don't fret one
of destiny's best perks pun intended is
build crafting your armor and weapon
loadout for different activities armor
mods can let you build for damage buffs
ability recharge and even these crazy
balls of energy that can suppress heal
zap or straight up explode
meanwhile certain weapon perks on the
slow gun can help them reload faster
than they reasonably should or grant you
better recoil stability some can
activate when you're crouched or work in
certain situations like dealing more
damage against bosses there are a lot of
opportunities to experiment we're going
to get a little inside baseball here but
what you want to keep in mind in terms
of what a good loadout is is to factor
in the meta bungie likes to shuffle the
cards based on player feedback and their
internal data they'll nerf weapons that
are really hot buff underused perks and
archetypes or rework them entirely the
meta changes every season so get what
looks cool feels good or makes you happy
[Laughter]
if you want to have a competitive
loadout look at the seasonal artifact if
you have the season pass and focus on
weapons with some of those cool mods
it's a good place to start for example
particle deconstruction is a mod that
has made linear fusion rifles real nasty
this past season and the rework to
arbalist or sleeper simulator has made
it a must have in certain elite endgame
activities like grand master nightfalls
or raids
also some perks might be great on one
type of weapon but not on the other some
are fine by themselves but might have
awesome synergy when paired together
conversely a perk that doesn't seem
great suddenly becomes even deadlier in
the right package that being said in
general it is a safe bet to aim for
perks that help your first shot land
true speed up your reload or give you a
damage buff in combat i can rattle off
some perks you want to look for real
quick so pvp benefits from perks like
rangefinder snapshot explosive rounds
opening shot kill clip rampage just to
name a few in pve you can mess with
perks like outlaw headstone subsistence
rampage vorpal weapon clown cartridge
the list goes on there's just so many of
them just keep in mind that some weapons
like swords or rocket launchers will
have their own exclusive perks now just
because the internet is yelling at you
to have a very particular loadout does
not mean that you should toss away
weapons with unpopular perks because
that is for you to decide there are a
lot of great perks that are not meant to
go in competitive pvp or raids but they
make blasting a bunch of minions a lot
of fun during patrols do not feel
overwhelmed it might be scary at first
but trust me you can play a majority of
the content without actually having to
worry about these best weapon rolls all
of this stuff really starts to matter
once you get into the higher tier of
content so until then enjoy yourselves
keep in mind there is enough information
overload to drive anyone nuts with build
customization and situational use but if
we are to break this down at a kind of
high level very generally speaking armor
specifically has two considerations stat
builds and mod builds and i'll use my
character as an example
every armor piece has six stats three of
them involve your movement and your
health bar so bear with me mobility is
how fast you run and how high you jump
resilience is for how much damage you
can take recovery is how fast you regain
back health when you're hurt each of
these three also determines how fast you
gain your class's special ability to
recharge back titan shields regen faster
the more resilience you have hunters can
dodge more often the higher their
mobility is and warlocks get their rifts
on a shorter cooldown with higher
recovery the remaining three stats
involve your abilities discipline
affects your grenade cooldown intellect
for your super recharge rate and
strength for your charged melee
abilities like fireballs hammer throws
or smoke grenades to name a few each
total character stat has a number value
out of 100 while your armor pieces
individually have number values for each
section out of 40 with your character
gaining a tier for every total
denomination of 10. so any total value
for a stat in the 50s tier 5 60s tier 6
and so on so take a look at my character
right now we're going to use him as an
example this is my warlock there are
many like it but this one is mine and i
really like the subclasses that factor
in his grenades like stasis dawnblade
voidwalker which are some of my
favorites so the two stats i want to
prioritize on this guy are his recovery
and discipline sure i'm slower than i'd
like and my super is going to take a
long time to charge up but the crucible
meta right now from what i can see has
shifted away from ability spamming
anyway so it's not really a priority for
me but what i was thinking when i made
this build is that i can personally
guarantee to myself that my riffs will
come back fast my grenades will regen
within 30 seconds at most and this will
let me use my subclass to its full
potential with my playstyle so i can now
consistently consume my grenade to fly
high and have perfect air accuracy as a
dawn blade or i can throw a freezing ice
stasis turret or i can overcharge a void
heat-seeking axion bolt and man that has
got to be good for at least a kill or
two if not an assist each time that i
use it okay
okay
all right
[Laughter]
right on so now that you can kind of see
where my thinking was when i made my
armor build you guys should be able to
do the same think about what you like
about your subclasses and suit your
builds accordingly a good goal is to try
to get at least two stats into the tier
10 category if you are lucky and can
maximize some mods you can even get 3
tier 10 stats so that covers the stats
but what about the other half of armor
building right the mods the important
thing to know is that mods are exclusive
to different pieces like your helmet
arms chest legs and class items helmets
will let you find particular ammo more
often or they can give you better
accuracy there are also mods tied to
elemental affinity and this might get a
little complicated but to make it easy
just pay attention to the symbol on each
armor piece and note if it's void solar
or arc take some time to read what the
mods in the last slot of each armor
piece do as well because these can add
special gameplay mechanics in combat
here are some examples you have war mine
cells which have fun perks based on
using certain weapons enjoy them while
they last because i'm pretty sure
they're getting reworked there are also
elemental well makers that help
regenerate abilities and grant extra
perks at the same time other mods may
have a hidden ability that will activate
if you have your build set up in a
particular way some of the best mods or
seasonal mods that cycle out passive
guard breach and clear oppressive
darkness these are all mods that will
make any veteran get a glossy-eyed look
with nostalgia fair guess to say witch
queen mods no different expect to see
the community go wild with some crazy
combinations this very season
so stasis was the first subclass to take
advantage of the all-new overhauled 3.0
system the 3.0 system is a new type of
subclass customization tree that
combines the subclass with two new
concepts aspects and fragments aspects
are class specific perks while fragments
are universal across classes you can mix
and match different fragments based on
how many fragment slots your aspects
give you some aspects will offer stat
penalties or bonuses as a trade-off for
the type of perks they offer and they
can do some cool stuff this season the
void subclass is getting the 3.0
treatment as well which is why its user
interface will look like stasis arc and
solar will have 3.0 iterations this year
in future seasons but for now the ui has
the older look that all of the
subclasses used to have ever since
destiny 2's launch
so you want exotics well you can get
them in lots of ways the more you play
the more chance you will have to get
exotics just dropping over time but
there are certain methods to raise your
chances at getting exotic weapons and
armor to drop the easiest way right off
the bat is to buy the season pass for
the seasonal exotic or just wait for zur
to show up and shop his inventory for
most other exotics zur is a vendor who
appears on the weekends each week he
sells 3 exotic armor pieces one for each
class and a random exotic weapon
he also offers an exotic engram that
will drop a random exotic tie to
whatever class you purchase it with be
sure to stash any legendary shards that
you get as that is the main currency
that he accepts there are also specific
exotic quests that will have you explore
certain areas or complete side quest
type steps these exotics do not drop
from the general loot pool so definitely
take some time to chase them down
for any exclusive exotics with vaulted
activities you will find almost all of
them in the exotic terminal this is
especially good for coveted raid exotics
like anarchy terriba and more lastly you
can check endgame activities that grant
exotic armor as a common drop such as
grandmaster nightfalls
however this is not something new
players will be expected to achieve
right off the bat your best bet is to
simply play the game take your time try
raid when you're ready and definitely
hit observe often
more times than not destiny is a game
that gives you better payout the more
that you play however sometimes rng will
screw you over and apologies in advance
we've all been there suppose you want
your character to simply be good enough
to play all the activities in that case
the best way is to grab a team and tough
it out through the new legendary story
missions completing the witch queens
campaign at legendary difficulty will
grant you one armor set which is at a
raid ready power level and that'll
affect the power level of all of your
other future drops otherwise if you're
simply a free-to-play player you will
most likely be spending a good amount of
time running strikes and fighting in the
crucible you'll hit the power level hard
cap anywhere from a day if you are a
maniac to a week or two of consistent
play if you want a really good character
with an elite pve and pvp loadout all
maxed out quests unlocked caught up on
everything that you'll need
well let's just say you'll need a uh
a good amount of time
okay
alright this is the most important thing
to know especially if you've been on the
fence with destiny or you had a bad
early experience in the past before they
iterated on the game without question
raids are the most difficult challenging
and rewarding activities if you never
experience them they're all worth trying
at least once lfg is basically just
looking for a group and it's a nice way
to get into these tough activities but
you want to be careful and make sure you
find a group willing to take on a new or
a rusty player and that they are patient
it can be daunting falling into a toxic
group that just wants to grind out the
raid as fast as possible there are
plenty of sherpa groups that are super
friendly and more than willing to help
the best case scenario though is to grab
a group of friends and run in blind
trying to solve all this [ __ ] yourselves
dungeons are fun raid lights and they're
also worth doing they're a lot less
hassle than raids requiring a team of
three players instead of six and a great
endgame activity to run if you have a
smaller group wanting a crack at
something different from the usual
activities beyond that crucible is my
personal favorite and where i spend most
of my time i'm a pretty good shot if i
do say so myself too i like that type of
energy
any pvp shooter fan will feel right at
home here with modes that reflect team
deathmatch domination conquest and a
competitive survival mode trials of
osiris is another pvp beast and worth a
try if you're a pvp die hard we have
another video that breaks down all of
the changes to the trials of osiris many
of these changes being for the better
otherwise you just want to explore i get
it in that case the story and seasonal
activities are where you want to spend
your time destiny has turned into an
evolving world and it's always worth
tuning in every now and then to see
what's been going on with the
storytelling each season also a personal
favorite there are plenty of hidden
secrets in the game in the patrol zones
that can be scanned by your ghost hop
into nessus go through a vex portal and
see how far you can go
destiny the witch queen is at max hype
right now and the story is about to be
incredible with all the build up over
the last seven years from destiny 1
coming to this moment if lightfall in
the final shape is going to be like
avengers end game then witch queen
certainly feels like infinity war and
i'm 100 here for it trust me if you
haven't played yet or you fell off i'm
sorry to say that you may have missed
out on some really cool shared
experiences but that's okay because
you're back now and there's even more to
discover and experience together and
that is all that matters see you on the
field guardian
[Music]
you